david johnson dj
alan how you doing man thank you so much
for coming on the program thank you
i'm so pumped and thanks to andy bittner
absolutely for introducing us
yeah what a cool yeah part of the lads
what a cool group
that you guys found yourselves
yeah thank you yeah yeah and what
occurred
even with terrance would occurred with
walt the
the walter russell uh
university of science and philosophy
university science philosophy yeah
i'm starting to see you guys more
now oh yeah okay because it it
you know it took we're trying
we're all kind of triangulating on the
same thing from different
ways like the nature of reality from
different ways and you guys are
definitely
handling it from a very science and
spiritual synthesis is where
we have a very deep similarity and then
i'm handling it from a very storytelling
way but you're handling it from i was
saying this outside from a very
mathematical physical virtual reality
style way and
i think that's exploration in that
direction yes
and so i think there's a very powerful
way
that we've been connecting for already
two hours even before we started the
show right
about all of the different concepts and
abstractions and embodiments of
these realizations
it's been super insightful and we're
gonna be we have a lot of really good
content
that you know dj brought a really
awesome
demo for us as well and so we'll be
unpacking that demo and he'll be
explaining
a lot of what he's doing right now at
argos vu
and you can find some of those links in
the bio below
i highly recommend checking them out
before we get to all this stuff on
simulation design
dj walk us through your journey who you
were growing
up and how you got interested in what
you care about today
oh wow so uh actually as as you know
today uh
it's my birthday for some reason and
and i do want to i do want to say that
this is a blessing because dj came on
the show
it's his birthday it's a beautiful
synchronistic moment that we are
celebrating this together
i love it right and i'm honored that you
came on my birthday it's so cool
thank you yeah thank you so thanks for
inviting me this is a surprise from uh
from
from some some synchronistic place so
uh uh i was born in saddlebrook new
jersey
in 1960 and uh grew up
uh my father was a flight engineer for
twa
and uh it ended up flying 747 so we got
to travel
when i was young which was amazing and
uh uh got into engineering he was
very into like flight systems et cetera
that type of thing
that uh uh go along with with uh
that uh that that type of job
so uh uh i was always intrigued with
both
uh music and uh uh
signals so i dove into electrical
engineering and then
uh uh extended that with uh computer
engineering
so uh graduated in 1986
and then uh it's been been a pretty
pretty wild
track to uh la and uh we can get into
that probably on another on another
episode
but the uh the uh uh the driving force
into
uh studying the
simulation uh design
as we're kind of calling this thing uh
started around 2001 uh i dove into
three-dimensional engine design
oh one one little point along the way in
1981
because a few people could say this 1981
i
uh did a work study program
from the school that i was at and
designed a video game for the atari
system
that went national so that was that so i
go all the way back so i'm
very very old school in that way and
uh so that that initial exposure
and uh the the little bit of notoriety
gained from that
kept me dabbling in the world of video
games
but uh i was always intrigued with the
possibility of using that technology for
something
a little bit more outside of the
standard commercial video game world
so uh that led me into
three-dimensional engine design which uh
it was there was a very large
enthusiastic community
of people around the 1999 into the early
2000s
designing you know in just in in this in
the spirit of linux
three different 3d engines and
everything
so uh uh dove into that pretty heavily
and i started a company called uh it was
it was a meditation virtual reality at
the time
and it kind of ties into all the things
that we're doing today
interesting so uh uh
so that was my my uh uh
initial toe in the water for for what uh
we're doing now so uh in in in the uh
the the aftermath of that i've worked
for an ai company in austin texas
and then seven years with the medical
device industry
so and that kind of that kind of
catapulted me back into the
into the the vr engine design world
so it makes sense hearing
about a lot of the
engineering upbringing also with father
that kind of
spurred a lot of that
side of things and then how i can see
also how that
stacked up over time to become more and
more around the sciences and the
engineering's and the
the 3d space designs like you're
describing
when did the the art
and the spirituality
where did that angle come from along
the way i think it ties it's something
that that the
the the good
tactile aspect of of uh
doing art and doing particularly music
because i studied music from
from as as a child and then oh yeah and
then it actually became
a short-term career when i was living in
florida
five years so yeah some kind of some
kind of distance
what was the instrument of choice uh
keyboard piano
keyboard piano so uh
uh the the the immediacy
of of of the experience of doing that i
found
lacking in the meticulousness of the
engineering
you know so i so i think there was a
balance we were talking about the duels
before
so there was this dual balance going
with that as well once again
yes okay so that was an example of it
and then
when did you get exposed to things like
the
planetary mystic traditions and how did
yeah
really really recently i mean the uh
the the the initial like deep dive
didn't start till
2017 yeah i think so and this is what
you know we were talking about rudolph
steiner and everything
and yes and uh then the theosophy
those those uh the the the the the
the the the mystery school avenues you
know
and interestingly how accessible all
this stuff is now
on the internet to be able to do some
fairly decent
uh cross-checking and research and stuff
so
okay so that that one has become a bit
of a
super intriguing pathway yeah i agree
that
the one of my favorite aspects to the
space of the internet is that we can
query it for the
absolute highest signal and so but you
have to know where to look for that
highest signal that's one of the hardest
things to know how to do
and so i've been definitely trying my
best to identify
where are the places that have the
highest level
spirituality science genius level
concepts and ideas that i can go
study because that's what it's the key
in my opinion that it the enabling of it
but it's double-edged because it's
very distractive for many people as well
i want to take us back
along the journey because i was looking
at this now i see some of the
engineering influence and some of the
art influence that
because that's obviously these polls is
really where we find
being able to go to these extremes and
then to synthesize
when we look back 40 years ago i want us
to walk through a little bit of an
evolution of what we've seen
because elon musk has this meme that's
now become
more famous where he says that we went
from
pong right to indistinguishable virtual
realities in half a lifetime
right and it's a very profound meme
because
it it makes you realize that
there's this accelerating pace of
technological change that's occurring
and then there's also the whole idea of
by entering into these
indistinguishable realities we ourselves
realize that this
already is one of those
indistinguishable virtual realities
right so there's that recur
property to it so walk us through
specifically because you were there
in the days designing project you said
game for atari yeah 6502. 65 would you
say
okay so now this is before i'm born and
before
some of our viewers are born but
specifically
what is it like because now we're going
to be showing people you know
argos vue and literally simulation
designs and these
insane environments that you're making
but yeah
take us through also that process of how
the engineering and design technologies
are
evolved over those like four decades
yeah it's remarkable i mean just as
as far as being kind of in the front row
seat
watching the whole the show take place
but uh
uh we we wrote that
that app it was all uh assembly language
so
it comes back to the m1 conversation
that we had for
to bring it full circle and i'll tag it
with that but uh
uh so the the uh
very small instructions set use op codes
to to define things
so you have a you have a uh uh basically
an instruction
what what what what the operations are
going to be into operants
and that that was the kind of uh
very very uh it's the right word for it
just cryptic you might say but once once
you kind of saw what was going on it's
basically you're manipulating things
right on the processor level you're
manipulating registers and
et cetera so uh you know full circle
you the the hardware uh uh initially
was uh uh growing at just just uh
you know double triple the rate of
what's with software
the the tools to to develop uh uh
uh different applications and uh
so you know this assembler
moved towards c and then c move towards
c
plus plus uh uh
object oriented uh type of uh
design etc and uh
very similar to the evolution
of uh of of dialects and languages
as we call them languages of course but
this this
this tie this this tie around back to
uh uh what's what's what's given
everything such a boost now is is the uh
parallel processing being able to have
many many cores on the system
and uh uh so you know
coming full circle this uh m1 chip that
came out just recently with apple
outperforming desktop uh systems
that's designed for mobile app low-cost
mobile apps uh
this this is using a reduced instruction
that's an
arm processor which is an advanced
reduced instruction set model
so you come back to the op codes again
and it comes back down
down to the beginning of the story so
so in a way i mean it's it's it's it's
it's an expansion
and a recursion on many levels but
but back simplification yeah yeah so
it's interesting so would it would it be
fair to say that
there's a
and there's this endless optimization
that's occurring to make things
more and more
to take less energy to
be less computationally intensive to
be enable more creativity
to enable more modularity
so these are kind of the trends that
have happened right
okay right right right okay the ability
to isolate
to to to locate yeah yeah that's that's
always the the
the challenge yeah the art isn't
necessarily the writing it's often
it's often the debugging exactly so
exactly because
the debugging gives you the the view of
what the design
is supposed to be that's right so it's a
conversation right
yes even yeah the yeah as much as this
is
artists our art this is also debugging
right
yeah yeah which is super interesting
yeah yeah that's right
we're
the whole planet is both one the perfect
uh artistic expression and the same time
as a
massive ongoing debugging yeah it's a
feedback loop
exactly yeah that iterative iterative
design yes
yes and that's the beauty of the the
paradox the enigma of it's absolutely
perfect
and at the same time it's a work in
progress right yeah
yeah interesting
so it's probably fair to say that
the last you picking this up
especially simulation design in the last
five years
it's been
this is the time for
the flourishing of this technological
space
and it's the perfect sort of peak in a
sense we've heard this also
become more of an interesting mantra
which is that
like my generation
this millennial generation and even the
gen
z afterward we're kind of the ones that
are
were too late to explore the physical
planet uh and were
too early to explore the space economy
and the cosmos which is probably gonna
be the generation alpha
and beyond the ones that are born like
today and stuff
but we're we're the generation that's
gonna explore the virtual worlds
that's what's been said about our
generation so
literally these this decade 2020 to 2030
we're going to see a proliferation of
simulation designs
right and our immersion right
into them right right and this is this
mirroring where it's
the the cyber nod as well as the
psychonaut
you know the exploration of the psyche
yes so it's it's it's a
natural organic melding of those for
some reason
really interesting yeah a cyber
psychonaut
yeah that's it to get into that uh
terence mckenna world
yeah that's it yeah yeah
interesting okay
so do you are you envisioning sort of
like
the same way that the proliferation of
websites has occurred in the last couple
of decades that you are going to see
a proliferation of these virtual worlds
i think i think so i mean the the the
ability to
i think one of the aspects that's a
little bit not uh
uh what's the right word for uh
band-aid too hard is is the
the that in that interaction of the
create creating the world itself
and it's it's like okay um instead of it
being pre-packaged and it's like here
it's it's the it's the involvement of
the the participant in yes building
their own environment around you know
we've we've had such a
uh i was thinking that the ant farm uh
metaphor recently and with text
you know our our ability to kind of
express
and understand reality through this
sequence of characters
is very myopic you know down down a
single pathway and now
now this ability to kind of express on
multiple
multiple dimensions you know of uh and
and have them feed once again feedback
to you
is is uh fairly new you know obviously
yeah and and again
a little bit uh and
creates a bit of vertigo one might say
because it's like
yeah this is a recur there's a recursion
this recursion aspect how much of this
is
yes us appearing into the mirror yes
i liked as you were saying that that it
came to me that there's this
our immersion into the
explosion of indistinguishable virtual
worlds
needs to happen in a way where the
conscious agent that is immersed in the
environment
has a co-creative say in it and that's
the recursion like in this one
as well right we hypothesize that we
programmed reality to have a quantum
mechanical free will
style feedback
with the conscious agent that is
immersed in it right and that
we will likely do that in the ones that
we make
next where there's a co-creative process
right with the agent what's the
motivation i mean is it comfort and
security or is it or is it exploration
it has to be all those things exactly
yeah
it has to be i don't know i mean i i
could see polarities there
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't make
deterministic yeah
it's it's like robert may's logistic map
where
you can program the deterministic
recursive telos but you have the
bayesian cloud of probability space that
is
creative and that it is that the
billions of conscious agents undergo how
it actually
unfolds but the the telos is
the recursive into the next explorations
yeah but sometimes they don't make it
because of the
the darwinian metaphysical filters that
occur
right those fermi filters so yeah on the
universal level
right which we're undergoing many of
them right now it feels like at the end
of the compression right
but then but here's the most opportunity
so the most opportunity as well
right we've we've we almost certainly
passed the asteroid
we're in the middle of the mutually
assured destruction one
we're in the middle of the anthropocene
one we're in the middle of the
bio warfare and artificial general
intelligence ones those are
kind of the ones that we're in the
middle of yeah and so we have to
enlighten ourselves
and what a place to find yourself that's
why when people talk about this on a
metaphysical level they say things like
earth is the place to be right now
because it's at the peak it's the nexus
the nexus right yeah yeah this is the
place to be
because we're going through such an
interesting fascinating challenging time
of being at that bottleneck of
uh are we gonna be able to pull through
and it's super exciting it's like
you know as william shakespeare says
that you know the earth is a stage and
the men and women are the actors and
actresses and that
um you know take the play
be have be take it seriously and have
fun at the same time
yeah yeah right yeah right right right
there's a duel
yeah i love it um
i wanna um as before we kind of
begin sharing some of the examples
because there's this um
there's this like weird um
the visuals will be really helpful so i
want to pull them up but
there's this like
an um an optimal macro level way to
explain how to make these simulation
designs
and so i hope we can do our best to kind
of
explain them because is maybe the first
place to start
is to say that imagine we have a blank
canvas and then like
you just kind of like start from that
you know point
well in the middle of a blank canvas and
then you paint
outward in some sort of an expression of
what
is happening from that point or like
what's the best way to
and like to kind of get people to get
the starting points of simulation design
and also how would you even program the
process of how
of how it comes about yeah yeah yeah i
can
pull it up or we can't we can i'll give
a little little
a little bit of a preamble to it because
i think it comes back to one of the
things we were saying before it's it's
uh
the the the initial idea
is is is almost invariably not told not
not absolutely but almost invariably
uh uh it's it's the catalyst
but it's it's really not what's going to
come out you know for at least
this is my experience you know it
depends on how harsh
the the design requirements are
but in in this world which which is
which is
given given the blue sky aspect of it
that that
initial spark is it's it's it's
it's the crucial little point of sono
luminescence
but what what spawns out of it are
the these the the the the the dendrites
and the axons of the thing that are that
recursive interactive
uh uh just
feedback loop you have with as as you
experience
what the system is doing itself and and
i find that that creates
like the most beautiful types of
programs
so that would be my whoa okay so are we
saying something along the lines of
that as you're kind of at this
quote beginning point in the blank
canvas and you're
using your imagination creativity that
there are specific
ways to program
from that start point that
can biomimic certain yeah you say i mean
you see opportunities
like golden ratios and these types of
things for instance yeah yeah
but you see that you see foreign that
you wouldn't come up with
on the on your the just the your
kind of analytical mind would not not
necessarily
the the act of doing it it will inform
you
of what the next step is often you know
yeah i find yeah exactly that well um
this is a very important point my
um my my ex-girlfriend
alexa who made a very profound impact on
my life she had this phrase that she
taught me when i was like 22 that
meaning comes from making
and so the process of the process
is so fascinating because you literally
get to unfold the next step
in what the process is and so i i love
this it's like
when you when you hone in on that point
and you undergo the sort of beginning
unfolding artistic process you might
start with something like that golden
ratio or whatever yeah that's
unfortunate which is intriguing to you
right it's super intriguing right
right but but but in that it will inform
you exactly
versus the one where it's like where
it's like okay i imagine it done
you know yeah that's also interesting
because then it's like the balance of
the
seeing the north star and knowing what
that is
but then having flexibility on how to
get there but also
picking something and then seeing where
that unfolds and then right and seeing
what opens up in the space
interesting um
and one more thing before we dive into
the demo
are the main existing
market trends that are driving
simulation design
are what what are the market forces that
are driving simulation design
i i probably i i i've allowed this
to kind of take take uh to take its own
you know world whirlwind path and
i'm aware of what's going on in the
industry but but i wouldn't say that i'm
i'm expert by any means because
it's it's more like uh by staying a
little bit outside of it
i have more freedom than saying oh i
need to follow this trend or i need to
follow that trend
and then like a use case sometimes we've
been at you know like
ko fez the congress on the future of
engineering software
and that we've done partnership
interviews there and there's a lot of
people that
love the engineering simulation space
and that so there's things like you know
when somebody's
doing an automotive or aerospace
engineering or whatever there's specific
parameters that need to be met for a
piece to a vehicle or a plane or
whatever
and then we'll run
millions of simulations on what the
optimal piece and materials and
connecting points are for the piece and
it's just hyper iterative versus a human
going through all of the
partial differential equations by hand
and so that seems to be one of the
market forces in a sense that's
driving the simulation space
and then i hope another one that is
going to drive this space
is one that we were talking about before
we started which was the chimps this
animated series to storytell and inspire
and awaken right
so hopefully there's more and more
message there i think exactly what's
coming through
exactly hopefully there's more market
forces
and maybe we can get some of the
millennial and gen z that are
in the influencer space that'll have
some of the resources
to basically say that we want to make
simulation designs of stories
to tell to awaken with these purpose and
meaning
they'll be an interesting see if we can
have a
a market force that comes in that's more
driven around storytelling and narrative
type thing right yeah right okay
so
let's see here we'll switch to the mixed
effect for you guys so for those that
are listening on
audio uh only we highly recommend
um for you to watch on video if you can
on youtube um
and we have a couple options we have
some mixed effects we have the full
screen we'll probably go ahead and start
on the full screen which is what
david wants us to
and we'll probably have you walk us
through
kind of what people are are seeing as
yeah yeah so
this is the the intro lobby for for the
uh for the vu
and uh uh the the
inside there just uh as far as just
thematic pieces i've got the taurus
you could stop it there you just go back
a little bit
it's just just for sake of the sake of
uh
uh thematic elements because we were
talking about the taurus and then
the the it's it's it's the mysterium
cosmog cosmography i guess from from
kepler
it's a it's it's a it's a play on that
and we we can see the uh
the the egg coming in and out so the egg
plays a plays a role here just as far as
a
interface element kind of thematically
so uh uh we can you can move it forward
from here because that'll kind of exist
are we are we saying that so
you know we were just talking about this
before we started that there's some sort
of like a
like a starting point to the
imaginative canvas right and so here
you picked with vu you picked
this and so the vu is in the sense this
environment
this is where this is basically the main
menu if you want but it's it's it's i
call it the la
it's often called the law the lobby in
vr applications you'll have a lobby to
start with and but this is vues
lobby this is live so in
vive or oculus or whatever platform you
would first pick
vu and then this is this is where you're
this would be the starting point which
is the vu lobby
that's right and now vu is going to have
its own selection of
experiences right yeah right wow so as
the en
as the as the so which one what lobby
are we this is the first this is the
intro
i mean like this oh here yeah right yeah
that's a good question
oh goodness this is what we've been
doing for
two hours the first two hours i hate
y'all we've literally been doing this
this is the the mirror recursion i know
it is
so ridiculously beautiful okay so
so um okay so and what in this in the
lobby
uh you're pointing out what you've
designed as
this is the like taurus the taurus as we
were just
discussing you know that as as that
comes up and uh
it it has play in the schauerberger
stuff which will tie in with the
with with the end here and cut full
circle so okay alpha omega on it i love
alpha omega
all right let's let's go back to it okay
so those those uh the screens on on the
uh on the front there
are are potential portals that you can
you can you can go
but there's also the ui that you can
pull up so i have my
uh it's a stylus that's uh
is is connected there that's a handle so
right in right in the beginning i have
the user guide inside the
the ui which is uh modeled after
uh it's an egg cross section as you can
kind of see i love that
so rainbow and rainbow colors right
right so each of those are buttons that
that give you different options in the
menu
and uh so is it is it that there's
you know in this lobby space that
there's the different
portals as you describe in the different
portals are like the
the different experiences that i can go
into in the vue
in vu right right and then the wand
which is what i'm
using has its own it's called a user
guide
on this there's it's actually got a uh
it's it's it's a
it's array that comes out of it so it's
kind of like it's kind of like a
lightsaber
or a a laser pointer yes so you can
click
click it and that's because then yeah
clicking into those experiments
it shoots the ray out just right along
the axis of it and i extended out the
tip
of the uh the vive the standard vive
uh model for for the controller and it
ends up being very
very useful because it ends up being
being a stylus and very precise
and i'm using that along with in the
future we'll be using
voice and other tools to basically i'm
using that as
my kind of my mouse and keyboard it's
your mouse right right
three-dimensional mouse yeah okay and
then one of the aspects that you'll see
here is is
uh actually uh
it was this was an interesting
collaboration because uh
luke luke womack who i told you about my
my partner
he he was my my uh we worked handy glove
with with the
daily development and then testing and
one of the with the quaternions we have
to do rotations
so one of the aspects of of being able
to move around
really really precisely within
the vu is the ability to grab space
so i can i can go in and i can grab
space and and go like this and it
rotates the whole space
yeah yeah yeah so this is a it's that's
a little novel
speaking of novels novel aspects so
uh uh so that that that controller ends
up being
uh uh uh it's it's a very interesting
uh experience to to be able to go like
this and then
yeah it's like you can imagine rotating
the whole room
so in a in part of it it's like kind of
what we were
uh we were talking about before we
started where i'm just kind of moving
my head in this case and i'm watching
you and the room right along with that
right and then another example would be
like maybe when we're doing like the
google earth and we kind of like click
and we drag
to the next kind of perspective on the
planet that we want to look at right the
earth is moving that's right exactly
that
exactly okay and i like that that that
user experience sort of
is it's really important actually a lot
of um the like
rhino and um other yeah
software right right but but the the the
the difference of the immersion
ends up ends up it it adds a it adds
another dimension to it when you're when
you're doing it
yeah you know so actually an even from a
really good 3d editor you know does uh
is rhino rhino has vr they do they do
already that's so cool yeah yeah that's
great
yeah i'm sure the yeah designers are
yeah
no it's it's it's this is a remarkable
shift
yeah yeah wow right wow that's beautiful
okay all right
let's keep rolling here
so what i've done here is uh we we've
we've moved into
one one of the portals okay which is the
cartesian space
okay cartesian and then and then uh what
we're what we're seeing
is these are attractors so the the
the the interplay is off uh a charged
cloud
but it's it's it's uh uh it's a point
cloud and particle system
but the uh the concept is kind of like a
charge
uh uh like a continuum of of of charge
and it sets up uh
velocities that occur because
the attractor is of the opposite charge
so yes here's our here's our polarities
again
yes yes so like you'll see here you set
up
set up different geometries of clouds
and then uh the the ability to
run the simulation is uh dependent on
the time frame that you select in the ui
and i'll show you at the very yeah you
could stop it right there just really
quick
at the very top there you can see uh
there there's a slider that selects
the the the time just like an
oscilloscope
so uh the the the different little
chicklets
up there going from red uh uh
on the left over to to the purple on the
right yeah
are are are are like uh uh they're
they're orders of ten
ten each each oh they're orders of ten
yeah
so so you can go from for instance
something like
like the nanosecond time frame into the
second time oh yeah yeah that's probably
two too far
or or in like millimeters to kilometers
or something as well in size
as well so that's what that's how this
is one of the
insights that that as far as those
feedback loops and then
the iterative processes you see from
scaling
that that that very tight relationship
of time to
the volume of space oh yeah that's right
so so that's interesting
so this this ad the oscilloscope aspect
of it
plays yeah was a big role so then yeah
would it so
the there's so many things here
um the first thing is that we clicked
into the
cartesian uh space portal right
so that this is now the like it's
x y and z correct environment so we're
in a three space
right okay and then there's other
portals where it's not like this
that it's different right right we're
going to show those different
there's there's there's a couple there i
mean we've got we've got one that's a
model the solar system and then there's
a harmonic analysis that we can
we can take a quick look at okay cool so
we're going to show you these are all
kind of like
in the explanation will be a portal to
yes to just
you know in intriguing ideas of what
we're doing
and the reason why we
are showing this as the first portal
is probably because the xyz
it's the most natural that we're
familiar with the most natural that
we're
familiar with and it may be i don't know
yet
because i'm trying to push my
imagination creativity beyond
the 3d style space
but it seems to be that this
style of universe design where it's an x
y and z
in the 3d seems to be
really natural in a sense like i'm
certainly pervasive
i'm trying to yeah like what like i'm
trying to think like how else would we
design
universes that's like right yeah so
anyway
but okay and then so there's that first
and the second thing the oscilloscope
thing super interesting so basically
it's fair to say that like if we
go to the
the level of this is the subatomic
particles um
we're going to be dealing with the this
both the size
and the time right um at those
kind of like nano meter levels
way down and then but then as if we if
we jump
um to the levels of planets um
we're also going to jump the size of
planets we're going to also jump to the
time scale of days and years right okay
right
so light years and light years right
right yeah okay
interesting and this is this this cosmic
uh quintuple jump
that that is has played in orders of
nine traditionally
that people have been looking at uh
pretty closely over time but i've seen a
big focus on that
where where you start thinking
scalarly it it it's
it's it's a very similar action going on
the whole
the whole way and you know one of the
big problems with you know
academic physics et cetera is this this
you know duality between
quantum mechanics and then classical uh
general quality and and the the
the this this quintuple jump of orders
of magnitude thinking in time
frames just just like this cosmic
celestial time frame uh
as you jump as you jump out and scale
the
the the the the window of times
scale directly and this is pretty
remarkable actually
you know it's just it's it's it's tying
these patterns together
you know so yes so that that's at least
the intriguing i love
that so so the is it the oscilloscope
that's tying the pattern that's what did
it for me once again this is this this
is this
in the doing it kind of presented itself
i i i
the the the app itself was was was
calling out
i need this interesting you know as i
was playing around yeah
wow okay all right we'll uh
yeah so i set up a sphere there's a
sphere sphere of charge and
and that's i think that's using a it's a
cube octahedron
as far as the the layout of the
attractors and as we started off this is
this is the movement of the cloud within
that oh
wow then you start seeing there there's
there's the
the the pulsing but then there's there's
particularly
interesting are these organic
morphologies you start seeing within it
you know and what i'm doing here is i'm
grabbing see i'm grabbing the space
and then yeah and then i'm going to be
moving you can kind of see it's kind of
like a little bit of a flower bud there
if you want to look at it coming out but
now i'm going to scale down
i i'm able to freeze the freeze the
simulation at that point
but i'm also able to fly with the uh
with the
controller i have a there's a there's a
a
a little thumb pad that i can move my
thumb on yes
and by the orientation it ends up being
the vector of my flight yes
interesting so yeah this is how it ties
back to the fpv stuff actually you're
moving yet so you're moving through
right on a vector right so if you think
of if you think of the pad as like
your your level like where your mouse is
on the desktop
by by being able to move the the
controller that's the plane that you're
moving on and then your thumb
yes moves is the vector from the center
okay so you can move in any direction
yes and then you can also adjust how
right right speed so this the smoothness
of the being able to fly is uh
that that was particularly particularly
necessary for
for uh uh making it a good experience
you know so
so i spent quite a bit of time on that
and that's so funny that that's
one thing that we don't have here in
this
reality the ability to fly yeah we're on
we're basically
uh two-dimensional on the surface
right of the planet right just super
interesting right
right this is why this beautiful you
know just
dive into the fpv stuff has been so
great for me
and let's see i have my my
my lanyard from newbie drone see all
right
we we had uh a call
maybe a week or two ago where dj sent me
his fpv which is first person view
right drone flying right where which is
a sport
yeah right and so that enables you to go
beyond the 2d
to the 3d fpv where you're flying the
drone
right so you're usually in a virtual
yeah
you're wearing headset headset right and
then
you take the perspective of the drone
right and then you fly the drone and
then that enables you to rise
up and down the left right and fly
through trees they're designed to be
acrobatic
and it's it's an art it's an art in
itself i've had the
great great opportunity to meet some of
the people doing it on the
the the forefront it's really amazing
interesting so fpv is what enables us to
enter the the third dimension of height
which is
right and it's like astral projection if
you get into like the sleep stuff so
so psychologically it's very interesting
wow yeah wow
and it's it's very awakening because it
also drives kind of a macro
level view of things that gives you that
bird's eye view so when you are flying
that
drone fpv and you're you go really high
up and then you look down at how los
angeles looks like and you watch
the cars and the people and the goods
that are moving around and
the birds that are flying and the way
that the trees look i mean
it awakens you in a sense because
otherwise you're only you're stuck at
the meso level
all the time right and so that's why
it's important to also look at the
cellular level and the subatomic
level so you can go between micro and
macro but
meso is really 2d in a sense like
and fpv is super interesting i think i i
definitely am going to um go out with
you guys i would like to come out
because that's going to be
really fast the whole that space is now
becoming
uh competitions people it's interesting
there's i mean there's regulate because
it's new
it's like it hasn't been regulated yet
and it's like it's it's like that's that
there's
there's a growing concern you know
there's an understandable reason why
people for public safety et cetera
but there's also the the freedom of
innovation
you know so so these these this this
tension is rising as the
hobby uh uh gets more and more popular
you know and
and uh so you know terence as i was
telling you
has been he participated in the uh
it was the protest in washington with
the faa they want to
require remote id so any drone that you
build
has to be able to log on to the internet
until you
tell the faa where it's at at any time
and there's a lot of kickback coming
from the community
yeah yes it's interesting balance
because you want to
ensure that like cars have
license plates right right and so you
want to have license plates
on drones as well that's what the idea
is
right but at the same time people that
have a car
in the middle of nowhere where they're
just driving it on their like couple
acre property they don't need a plate on
that right car
so it's like this weird balance right
between people it gets into what i mean
gets once again into the 3d aspect of it
it's like
okay what's property and it's like the
faa wants anything
three inches above the ground there you
go and it's like
who's you know three inches of three
inches above the ground not even three
feet
that was three and one and like all of a
sudden i'm
oh yes i have to register yeah yeah as a
human yeah
yeah so anyway it's about all the birds
they have to register in the f.a.a.a
it's live and it's dynamic and there's a
lot of passion in it
super interesting the more we enlighten
the more
we don't have to worry about malevolence
and that's an interesting thing too is
that we can become
our own uh consensus decentralized
trust organism where we don't need some
sort of a hierarchical style of control
right um and so we should do our best to
have that style
of grassroots enlightenment so that
right yeah
right right and that solves a lot of our
downstream issues
um another thing as we explore this is
you you started using the word uh
attractor
so the way that we've been using a
tractor is when we talk about kind of
that like north star
right or the uh the god head if you will
and that
as an individual you have your north
star in your 80-year window of
biological time where you want to
achieve your
transcendent noble aim and at the same
time the civilization has its
strange attractor godhead where it's
like that recursive telos that we're
talking about
and so the the godhead the attractor in
a sense is
some sort of a uh
mathematics that the system
moves towards and so like
in this case uh you can set
is it you said you used the word
attractor
along the same time that you used kind
of you called it a potential cloud
right charge charge charge cloud okay so
then what so
you can look at it you can look at it i
mean it's the i mean the the beauty of
mathematics is that it
it can be used as a metaphor for many
things too you know
but you can look at it the way that i've
been looking at it
is uh so you have a charge say you have
a charge cloud of electrons or ions and
then
and then the attractor is the oppositely
charged
right so so so then you have like your
coulomb's law that's
that's that's that's pulling them that
that's that's that's the
that that's how the force is exerted and
then
and then the it creates a momentum
and then that's all calculated per frame
so i see so the way that i write it
is which is kind of an another
interesting recurs
recursive aspect is you write
you you write like the entire code for
for
for one and all of the so so in this
case i think there's like 240 000
particles which which which i'm using to
represent
a cloud right but
each each one of those particles runs
all that code i see
so yes and this is why when you
distribute it out on a gpu
you can get just amazing amounts of
processes i see so
is this something like where the strong
nuclear force with an atom
has specific attractors that are
enabling the neutrons and protons
and then that are enabling the electron
that that cloud
you could you could argue that something
like that and then and then that way
i mean also you know you could argue
gravitational
gravitationally and that but that's one
of the let's say 250 000 or whatever
that are
in this representation right and then
further as you can see that this whole
250 000 representation has its own
attractor as well
so it's layers of attractors because you
can say that this is moving towards
something can be
can be yeah okay wow okay
wow so there's like layers of attractors
uh or like yeah and whole hollandically
yeah hold on inside of horns the cell
inside of the body inside of the
civilization this comes into the
idea with uh jim leninger which is the
it's it's the filament within filaments
you know and as as we go on we'll look
there's a solar solar system model
okay that we can we can talk about but
but it's it's
exactly what you're talking about okay
okay
so i think as as i remember putting this
together
so now what i i scaled so now now it
appears to be
like the size of a football field from
my stamp when i'm flying into it
so so each one of those those little
they look like paper airplanes there uh
is that like the geometries
those are like the geometries the j
that's the geometry of that of that
point cloud so
at that point that's the vector and then
the color is the velocity
so so it ends up being a a velocity map
of each of
each of those points so okay um so of
so it's a vector and of velocity
the point right as far as the mag the
magnitude is the color
yeah okay because it's that
the because you have
you have you have the uh
is it in in like a tensor field
you would have both the uh the
vector and the scalar or like how far
it is so like okay so vector scalar
you and you have like eric weinstein
talks about it as rules
and protractors right so there's the
ruler is the scalar
right and then the protractor is trying
to tell you what angle
the vector is at and so is it something
like multiple yeah
something like that yeah definitely i
mean each each one contains
you know i mean the spinners etc all the
all these different aspects
but in in in this case it's it's
containing the normal
to to the to to the direction
of of the velocity of the pull and then
uh it's uh uh
the the the magnitude basically so
and this is so and and what ends up
happening outside by
by looking at the entire field you see
you see these
these natural tendencies you know yeah
that that that are
like like the the the collective wave
that forms like a
uh murmuration you know yeah with with
birds you know
and they happen they happen naturally
you know interesting and that's where we
tie in the rupert shell drake
yeah magic field kindness right you can
kind of see them happening organically
you see organically happening
interesting so then
the way that the way that this currently
looks with these uh
geometric representations that are that
look
kind of morphic the um is similar to
like the school of fish or the flock of
birds
that are flying or swimming right or
like humans as well as
and then what are the behaviors that are
happening that are causing it this is
a very simple behavior and and
[Music]
even using a simple behavior you get
very very beautifully complex
and just once again like i said or
organic results
out of it you know and did you move it
to a different space or is this still
the same space
it's the same space i'm just using a
it's a fibonacci spiral as a point cloud
oh whoa
okay so so you can see as and it's only
one attractor in this case
so they're all they're all passing
through that one attractor
so you'll see it from the front here
yeah
so here you see the screen
so you're seeing all these i see that
you can see the toroidal aspect though
you see the
these these this scrolling and then
you know anyway super super enjoyable as
far as a phantasm goes you know
i'm so so curious about that one okay
wow all right that was interesting so
are we saying that like
what's going on here is is uh there's
an an attractor at the
uh at the origin at the origin right
oh my gosh in this case oh my gosh yeah
okay and then the whole the entire space
passes through it
and inverts you could look at it that
way
yeah just getting so so much
so many of my metaphysics are getting
augmented right now
so when we look at something like uh
excuse me like the idea of uh
you know like maths town has a
incredible
um benoit mandelbrot infinite fractal
zoom
right where there's an origin point and
then it's just this like insanely
gorgeous
infinite fractal zoom that's occurring
yeah yeah and so
that you can do this with fibonacci in
the sense this golden ratio style
right from the origin point and that
in like in metaphysically if we think
about it as
as consciousness exploring infinity
there's some sort of uh source
origin source code origin point
where there's the you can think of it as
a
as a source light that's refracting
through these infinite combinations of
of realities um
that consciousness gets to immerse
itself as
as a exploration as an explorer
through the analysis of the
phenomenological states that occur
in those realities and that so this is
kind of where it's super interesting
like
metaphysically because i'm starting to
see a similarity here between
what you're expressing and between kind
of what
like in you know in high level
perception
i made this in in
the chapter 10 on
on infinity where
where i also put
the
origin point in that mandelbrot infinite
fractal zoom to be
in that kind of center point that was
undergoing this
infinite exploration so that in itself
could be the attractor the source code
the
the exploration i mean yeah i mean i'm
i'm really
origins are very interesting yeah
yeah multi-level metaphor yeah
there's a thing called the orbit of zero
i think with with uh male 1 abroad so
that's that's
the orbit of zero orbit of zero right
but anyway that's a whole that's a whole
it's another rabbit hole to dive down
wow okay this is so cool
okay all right so yeah we'll get back to
the
continuation of this so this is a sphere
passing through itself
here you can see the the attractor is a
little bit off
off-center and you start seeing this
cardioid come out come out of it
right yep so and you can see it it
bounces back and forth it oscillates
between the two orientations
and then i think i i have another one
here where it's right on the edge
and then then you you start seeing these
radiation patterns as well that
come out of it that are pretty
interesting yep so
yeah yeah yeah i love that yeah and then
and then you can
you can really see that kind of that
that
central focus through the you know
the the the the calculation that i do
as they pass through that once again
there's a single attractor
but uh the calculation has to take uh
in into account uh a zeno's paradox
as you come down into uh
smaller and smaller uh uh lengths
as you approach that that's uh as
as remember we're talking about one over
r and as
as as that as that r decreases down to
zero
you get an explosion of of the of the
over the floating point
decimal so i have to do a bit of a xenos
paradox
there to get to get the accuracy
precision i'm looking for
so but you can kind of see that this
very interesting
uh uh iconic
conic behavior along with the uh
the the yeah the the the the
the toroidal nature of the yes yes
i love how close we are to that or well
apparently it looks like we're closer to
the origin point
yeah you're getting close to the origin
there yeah so and you can see it see
them all coming in
whoa there whoa
so you know one of the aspects of
developing this that was
made it so uh uh
nicely iterative was was the ability to
have that
that oscilloscope aspect to it where i
can change these time frames and see
those
see how it behaved this is running
decently fast here but
is that are those on the wand do you
have the
like you have your scale invariants like
kind of like on
the it's in the ui remember those
chicklets that are up on the on the top
the different colors oh yeah those oh
that's when there's a slider
that's right okay so red on the left is
is that the smallest or the largest
uh i have it on the left that's the
largest
right that is each incremental time
space would be like the wavelength
itself
right in our spectrum right right okay
so red is
longest and then the the nano pico
family
it ends up being five orders of
magnitude
okay so one so or this would be like
ten thousand one thousand one hundred
ten and one or something yeah something
like that exactly
going from red to purple right yeah okay
excuse me
interesting at the top of the of the uh
user interface that you were showing
yeah yeah got it got it
that's how you jump between the that's
your oscilloscope that's right
right okay it's a spatial ex
the the cornerstone aspect of it of the
of this
portal of the vu is is the the the
so this is the oscilloscope spatial
oscilloscope
interesting spatial that's that's so
interesting
right instead of a signal where it's 2d
it's like the entire
space you would say that the spatial
oscilloscope is the cornerstone
of the vu i would say the this this uh
early access version i would say
definitely that's cool i like that a lot
that's super cool yeah
interesting and again would you say that
the
the oscilloscope
it enables scale and variance
no it enables you to explore like the
different time frames and then
the one thing that was really uh uh
enlightening to me by doing it as
is the direct relationship of of
perceived volume to to time
so so oscilloscope brings uh
the relativity of time and
volume or distance it's super apparent
yeah yeah
together so that if you're at the yeah
the 10
000 scale all the way down to one scale
right here right okay if you if you if
you become if you've become tiny it's
like it's like
your your millisecond will will seem
like yes yes
yes so so the oscilloscope the reason
why i keep going back to the word scale
and variance scale and variance breaks
down into
time and like distance or volume yeah
yeah yeah
total sort of weight okay okay
interesting
so this is get this this is getting into
a little bit
there's a thing with an oscilloscope
called elisages pattern
so so with this i'm i'm doing uh
12 concentric rings that are of the same
radius
right but i'm i'm varying
the incremental angle as you go along
and
because because one of the things that
starts popping out of all this
uh exploration is harmonic analysis
yeah and you start to see you start
seeing where the nodes are
on on this is this is a fairly
simple type of idea except it ends up
producing some pretty
pretty beautiful results when you start
seeing where the harmonic nodes are
here's here's a five node and you can
kind of see
if you if you think of the sand dollar
kind of kind of
morphology comes out of it that's just
12 rings
producing that right so and then
i've got it set up so by rotating the
handle
you can change the incremental uh
angular change of each of the rings
and that's how i step oh i'm stepping
through this here
so this is just a coin there's a four
yeah right
and uh so one of one of the ideas of
like the you know continuing development
is is being able to use sound like your
voice to generate these type of
these type of dynamics as as
and so the the the you could consider
this
a an incremental uh stage towards
towards that endeavor yeah
like something uh where we had we just
had a show
with uh brandon howard where we were
doing the psychology of sound and we
were unpacking
the solfeggio and schumann's and all of
the
the different herzes and the ways that
those can binaurally can
influence us towards peace or creativity
or
happiness or bliss or whatever emotions
like right yeah right
so there's also this virtual immersion
component to it of the it's funny
because on his euphoria app
he has a visualization that's happening
of the uh
binaural frequency that's occurring
right now if i'm in the immersive
environment right okay right
when you do it i mean you're doing that
type of thing with phase variation that
it's naturally too natural to do uh
listed just patterned on an oscilloscope
but
this is an example of doing one
three-dimensionally so
so for instance whoa so would it would
it be fair to then say that
um when we look at like what the
what is it seven point three eight is
this
earth's schumann resonance right so like
that hurts and so
but it would be fair to say that then um
there is
the different like you said you chose
12 of the yeah yeah in this case
yeah and so you can choose the different
the 12 or if you want to do 18 or if you
want to do
144 or whatever people want to visualize
right right right and then you can find
that there's different
uh
and sometimes it's like it's like
modular arithmetic like for instance
you take it like like a clock is modulo
12
this is why 12 is you know 12 is 12 is
that 12 is actually
not organic and natural you know from my
exploration at least you know yeah yeah
so but uh uh
modulo 8 modulo
boolean is modulo too you know so so
yeah
so just you know as you as you repeat up
so so
these this type of clothes instead of an
infinite mathematics system you close it
by having a
having a truncation you know so
that that that exploration uh leads very
uh uh directly towards harmonic analysis
is it also then fair to say something
like when people talk about the
like spiritual vortex that's in sedona
arizona people talk about stuff like
this a lot
it's a possibility that there's
literally a planetary resonant node
in that location right right those are
the kind of things that we're playing
with understanding
right right or that means and then you
start thinking the scalar again you know
as okay what is what what are the what
what's the fundamental of that is
is that an overtone or or is it yeah
yeah you start
yeah you start thinking this you know
yeah yeah your
scale time and variance yes
so just go through a couple couple more
of these and then then
[Music]
get it so so i've been working with uh
uh terence howard for the last two
two and a half years and one of the
aspects of his his geometry is certainly
harmonic analysis and uh
much of this leads in in that direction
he's
he's taken the flower of life and by
extrapolating it and
into three three dimensions uh
and links back to our quaternion
analysis
you start you you you you you get these
fundamental
wave conjugations that he's uh he's he's
created and he's he's
he's absolutely impassioned by
so it's something like uh like the
because okay so we have on our
we have a you know in this also this
other um asset that you prepared for
for the program there's a there's a
bunch of
of of awesome content in here um
and some of it is you know deeply
related to you know the golden ratio
we're just talking about and
there's this quatturians this is
interactive you know grant sanderson
three blue
right one brown uh yeah who does these
incredible
visualizations mathematically of these
spaces
um and so is then the
idea that um that there is a
oh this is the this is the there's one
that's yeah it's at the bottom
at the bottom yep that one this one
right okay
so this one's actually uh manipulable
yeah yeah you can just
yeah i love it there's grant's voice
he's awesome
that's great okay and then so then we we
ourselves can click and drag
through this right we can right add so
we come here we add
well we had a sphere and we add a second
sphere
right and then and then
with like the uh the i j or k
you can vary those yep just by dr you
can drag and then they'll vary
so you start see start seeing this
non-linearity
start coming up and then it it it's
pointing towards
some of the geometry that terrance's as
uh
is proposed and and uh uh these the
the idea of four bubbles coming together
you know
whoa so and so we'd need a couple more
spheres
yeah you can yeah
and so now with these spheres now you
have four of these
and there's so there's some and so it
looks like there's three spheres and
then one plane is that
is there's that just one big sphere that
last one's just huge or something
it it it it's it's a it's it's a
function of where
of your orientation you know how it's
projecting
so oh yeah so but the one thing that i
think is the most profound about this is
is you start seeing these uh the
it it's this it's the same geometry
as uh the the relationship between
electric and magnetic fields
yeah you know okay and they're they're
always orthogonal to each other
but orthogonal doesn't by no means mean
cartesian
you know so uh so and then this opens up
this is this is this is the big rabbit
hole ultimately so
oh okay so
there's there's a
representation of electromagnetism
that's apparent
you can't you can you can map it on if
you look at the like for instance
just one plane or one one sphere opened
up
it it it shows these same uh uh
field dynamics as a transmission line
cross-section yes so
and then it could either be that or it
could be
an infinite line of of a transmission
line or it could also be
toroidal you know so okay and then
there's once again a cross section so
you're talking projection but
now now what we're talking about is a
projection into
three space yeah so the this
often is and i see it so it's hard to
get it's hard to get our head around
yeah so yeah and it gets back to our
recursions again
whether whether whether this simulation
yeah right so wow okay um
and so uh again terence
howard right is doing
a uh his uh his his idea of leveraging
you said it's the harmonics in the
with force it's the fl the flower of
life the flower
using the flower of life but but but but
using it as a
the like simply like kind of kind of a
a cookie cutter into the three in into
three dimensions the projection of
the spaces that get formed out of that
and uh
i think it's actually the next part of
the yeah i was just about to
just kind of we kind of saw you for a
moment
with that flower of life that was
happening you had one as well just a
little bit
right that was right and so he's so he's
kind of taking that to another
right and it's it's i mean it's
interesting how ancient that that symbol
it is
and then and then how it how it is is is
pointing towards
uh harmonic considerations you know
yeah and and the the the this is this is
our
there's a flower line right so so so
so this is this is his geometry his
website right yeah i think
yeah yeah i built this for him oh that's
dirt yeah that's awesome yeah so
so but the the that one's called the
huntian
this is he calls this a light unit a
light unit
interesting that's an albert that's an
alberian
and then the final one is is called the
heavenly
so he he builds these like he's he's
he's remarkably interesting he's
remarkably
uh pristine and meticulous by
building building these he builds him
out of acetate and it's just
he's he's absolutely impassioned by it
that's it and
it's really remarkable
now would it be fair to say that
the usually is it right to say that the
pattern the repeating pattern
is the p it's p periodic
is that what it's called periodic
spatially spatially periodic
so is the hypothesis that there's this
sort of like light unit that is
spatially periodic
that's maybe yeah yeah
relating to relating to uh uh walter
russell walter russell right and also
the planck volume right there
right and it started zero point energy
you know as we were talking about
those that that are decreasing to zero
okay
similar okay yeah it's in the same vein
okay so are we trying to are we thinking
that there's
because you know clee irwin is also
interestingly we've had him on the show
twice and he he
and my quantum gravity research are also
trying to sort of identify what this
style of are there are there is that
kind of one of the big focuses is to
literally go
beyond because the greek said adam and
we were like okay how about sub
atoms subatomic right and then now we're
looking at the particles and
yeah yeah i mean i i personally like
entertaining
the continuum all the way down all the
way down and then and then
there's this this necessity for putting
numbers on it
is is i i think i think it's ego driven
and
because i want to be able to tag my
grand measurement system on it but
this is my own by the way my own
personal personal i
believe you know oh so that it goes it
goes all the way down and all
and all the way up yeah um so then
it's something along the lines of when
you're looking at that muscle level the
human level
and then you go right yeah we're going
down in these quarters it's always in
relation to that in relation to that so
for now because this is where the
conscious agents
right right and then we go down to the
oscilloscope because yeah right right i
see
so we're going down down down to um
to the uh to the plunk volume
level all the way down and then all the
way up to the
universe multiversal level right okay
right okay
right and then i mean it's always in
relation to that relationship yeah yeah
yeah jeez oh my gosh this is so
insane gosh i can't like
it's just like it's great because i
spend so much of my
my awareness on
uh just that you know that
that simultaneous that symphony we were
talking about where it's like we bathe
in the ocean of oneness
and we uniquely artistically express
ourselves with our instrument and melody
in the world and so i
i spend my awareness bathing in that
space as much as i can on a
moment-to-moment basis and it's gorgeous
beauty peace such a non-existence
consciousness bliss
but also when when people come along
like
you that do this like
here's quaternions and here's this this
uh
simulation design with light units and
flowers of life and look at all these
manipulable mathematics and
uh like gm geometries and
yeah and and it's play it's play it's
only good when it's i mean i love it
and it's like it only happens when it's
play
but you you definitely bathed me in a
unique you baptized me oh good
yeah it's definitely a baptizing that
happens in a unique way because i
i take a lot of it from uh from i i
think what was interesting was that you
know
like you know eric said something along
the lines of that uh
he eric weinstein said that he left the
planet
when he began taking physics seriously
okay you know
math and physics seriously okay and i
think that that's fascinating because
i think you're beginning you're probably
in your intermediate stages of leaving
the planet or maybe even
advanced stages of leaving the planet
because you're taking this
very seriously um i don't know if i ever
was here
yeah exactly i don't know i'm not local
i'm not even local what are you talking
about yeah yeah
yeah and so you know that's starting in
a sense i'm in the beginner stages of
sort of like making the realizations in
a mathematical and physical
physics way which is making me leave the
planet slowly
um you're already there oh i'm already
yeah well i'm there i'm there in a
conceptual
sort of scientific and spiritual and
philosophical artistic storytelling way
but when it's grounded in the actual
like math and physics of these
quaternions
uh now we're in a different sort of
level of of of play right right yeah
yeah i mean i i only dove into them
because i it was such a functional thing
you know yeah it's like it would sound
exotic you know it's like ooh you know
and and then
you could but because they were so
functional it's like they became
even more intriguing you know yeah
because the functionality that's it yeah
and that that
kind of also ties into how like we are
you know the designers we designed it
this way because of functionality
utility that's why it's this way right
that cartesian style plane is this way
because it could potentially be the
optimal way to design realities
in itself um seems the most apparent
you know and that's why that needs but
the cube isn't as as beautiful to me
as as like the tetrahedron oh the
tetrahedron
but they open up problems i mean this is
the anyway
another rabbit hole but this is kind of
where the uh
there's a thing called the pythagorean
comma and it's where
if you extend fifths like like
octaves will always double right so you
go octaves all the way up and all the
way down and track them
very nicely mathematically right yeah
but if you do the same path with the
fifth
which which is which geometrically is
pretty interesting being
three halves or or two thirds it's like
even even though the 12 comes out of
this two
when you come back to that you come back
through through the cycle of fifths
to that to the to that octave they don't
match so there's a pythagorean comma
there and this is kind of like
a crack in cartesian geometry one
might argue a potential cracking
cartesian geometry that's interesting
right
yeah whoa yeah and you wonder if that
crowd is super intriguing therefore
if there's something that has
potentially to do with
where we can learn our source code
through something perhaps i mean this is
why the
you know the music is uh like
the piano is well tempered you know they
have to temper it in order to in order
to have
it be able to play in all different keys
yeah otherwise otherwise it would only
be
it would only match with one key yeah
yeah
when before we started we were talking a
bit also about uh frank chester and the
chester hedren right how we had him on
the show awesome
and he unpacked for us sort of the
relationship of what it
means to think about a this
if i if i'm getting this right seven
sided yeah the chest the hedgehog
and that you have a uh like a
that he's identified as like why the
heart
is the way that it is inside of the body
and how it's doing that
that that spinning that twisting
style love dubbing right and that
there's that similar uh
i think or the aurora borealis on the
oh yeah yeah on the north and south
parts of the planet right right
you start seeing these opposed vortices
and
and and uh this is where you know the
the exp my
initial exposure and uh intrigue with uh
uh electric universe was these birkeland
currents that i was telling you about oh
yeah where you have
where you have uh concentric uh
cylinders
of charge rotating and and counter
rotating
and uh super intriguing you know
yeah that's you can just click on that
you can kind of see like the the the the
the the solar apex this is
this is actual satellite data
uh uh pulled together
showing the the the it's it it's a
perspective from the north pole of the
sun
so you can see you see this counter
rotation right at the
uh at the point
to me this was was just a major
confirmation of
of of being on the right track you know
so
okay and i like how you call it it's
like a the
polar vortexes is that kind of yeah
there's a thing called
called the solar apex that points in the
direction of movement of the sun
and thus the whole solar system yeah
through
through through futures through the
galaxy
and uh so this that that movement
creates a there's a helix that's formed
by that okay okay
is it fair to say that there's a
helix that is formed at the center of
the milky way at the black hole
and there's a helix that is formed at
the center
of our sun of our solar system at the
sun
and then there's a helical center that's
formed at the center of our earth i
think that everything
everything's moving right yeah yeah you
know yeah
matter and motion yes yes okay okay
so so by definition there has to be
those okay
okay over time interesting
so it's all you know it depends on what
it's relative to your emotion
measured relative to right
yeah yeah
yeah so this um yeah you had uh
you had in here a lot of other really
really awesome
content we have more to sort of look at
as we also take you through the rest of
the
video um we should definitely get
terence on the program
let's make that happen we can also all
talk on the program which would be very
interesting to have us
all unpack we want to unpack
the design of our reality and
and just universe design simulation
designs these this is
stuff that's obviously extremely aligned
with our our ethos
awesome yeah
so this is uh this is a app uh
i i did with uh eugene bagashoff who is
a
he's a physicist that that lectures with
the
electric universe and he also was was a
featured speaker at the observing the
frontier
conference in albuquerque and this is
this
this is uh this is a web app actually
so this shows the uh the the
the different scales of uh
the the local interstellar cloud yeah
and so so this is like the perspective
from pluto
and then this is coming out to like
where the ibex
probe is and then if you keep on moving
out this would be the local
interstellar cloud and then finally we
move out to
gould's belt so so you're you're scaling
out further and further
but still you're just in a very small
corner of the galaxy
yeah right and that's the galaxy in the
you know the cross section there
but this this th this this is showing
this
you know center of the tourist pipe
going going down through it
and uh this was inspired by a
a guy named jim weninger but one of the
things that's really intriguing are
these
uh if you if you go back to kind of a a
geocentric view of it
these little protractors are pointing at
the gala it's the galactic plane the
ecliptic and then the
celestial plane so they they show
and it's it's something that
interestingly terence's geometry
kind of points out too we kind of locked
into that as we were playing around with
it
so that's the galactic plane you can
kind of see there yep
and then uh uh then
the ecliptic and then i think i'm lining
up with the celestial there
you're kind of walking us through that
uh oscilloscope
here because we're going out from the
yeah so i want to think of the system
skills the galaxies right exactly this
is this right right
right interesting i like this sort of
immersive um
oscilloscoping for young people i think
it's super interesting and like
if we could in a sense go one more um
set
of order of magnitudes inward to the
micro scale of the cell and atom and
subatomic
right then we can that'd be interesting
to span the whole right spectrum right
right
and i think i think this is our
anthropocentric nature
it's like you start looking i mean just
just in in the range of animals that
we're familiar with you can see this in
action you know
just the the frequency of behavior of
something like a
you know a hummingbird versus an eagle
you know the hummingbird is
operating much more quickly obviously
yeah than a than an eagle and then
you know move up to something like an
elephant which is moving so slow but
it's related to the scale that frequency
related to the scale and this whole idea
of like oh well his brain is a big nose
this is nothing to do with the size of
it
that's just the frequency you know so
that's interesting so uh
this is there's ramifications of this
consideration interesting
yeah the hummingbird is
heart beating and wing flapping super
fast
compared to yeah right right but then
the environment becomes like it's like
syrup you know the air that we
interpret as something so thin and
everything by being small like that it
becomes a
it becomes a more viscous oh you see oh
is it from its perception
that's interesting so also for the
hummingbird
it's more like molasses right really
like it's like you can see it you can
see
and this is the beauty of our high speed
cameras now yeah you start seeing the
motion and it's like oh it's swimming
you know
it looks like it's swimming oh that's
interesting right
oh my goodness it's really relative
really relative right wow
wow it's interesting we're always
anthropo central yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's very it's it's very
delusional it's super delusional yeah
because
yeah though because if that's really the
yeah the perspective of a hummingbird
yeah and
uh idea as well is really fascinating
because
if the you know if yeah if the snake's
seeing an infrared and if the
dolphin and bat use sonar and these
types of things
then we're were way out of
of of our ability to try and understand
what that would be like to use those
characteristics of
of pers perception and existence
phenomenology in general right um
right and let alone a dog or a cat
that's
yeah that's sitting here which we're
always trying to project a human
perspective right right yeah and you can
see it in a lifespan too you know i mean
it's
it's it's that it's scalarly related as
well just you know
yeah it attracts with size and because
even that dog
scent right that scent thing for dogs is
such a serious
that we don't have anywhere near our
qualia representation of right so
like it's like it's like as uh
donald hoffman said on our show he's
like
try to imagine a color that doesn't
exist
right imagine a color outside the color
wheel right now you're like what do i do
to try and imagine a color outside of
the color wheel you're like i don't know
how to do that
right and that's similar to like this
qualia of
a dog's smelling or the
sonar of animals right yeah
right you're like you're trying where
there's like a fourth cone
in certain for a visual perception for
uh seeing a specific band of of light
between
i believe it's like red and orange like
so people some
i think specifically women can see a
certain amount like maybe like your
shirt
you can see a little bit more right of
the color too right right and i'm just
like i don't know how to do that and so
that sort of idea of there are so many
phenomena there's some
infinite phenomenological states for
consciousness to explore eternally and
that's potentially what the metaphysic
is
of that oneness that is infinitely
exploring different
qualias and phenomenologies and and that
we we are that we've been that we will
always be that
right welcome to the party right
[Laughter]
thank you this is the kind of stuff that
we talked about on the program i
uh i just i love over time honing more
in on the synthesis of science and
spirituality
on some sort of like a metaphysic that
we can sort of rock with
and right vibe on you know yeah that's
right you jammer and i love it right
i love that okay let's uh let's see what
else we got in the
we're almost done with the with the demo
everyone
yeah and we're still in the same portal
we're in that same portal yeah
we're just yeah the last the last piece
is the is this uh
it's the it's the solar system model uh
as jim wentinger's
solar system model and you'll see the uh
the helical nature of this i have a
projection of the helix
that it rides on and uh
so oh there it is yeah wow
so wow so if you project over time the
orbits and then
the the the movement of the solar apex
which has been measured by the way so so
so they do know in fact that it does
travel but i've got it so you can
you can adjust the uh the
the amount just just for for sake of
visual uh interpretation you know so
and this is that
this is i mean this is interesting
because his his model is
is the uh the idea of filaments within
filaments
and the hope vibration there that you
you're bringing up yeah
shows this in spades and once again this
is a
projection 40 projection into three
space
you know okay
and then again a a 4d
projection into three space it's
super interesting yeah niles johnson's
just like just check his stuff that was
amazing
okay niles johnson is the professor that
i was watching teach me about the
quaternions
he's so interesting yeah niall johnson
shout out to niles johnson i emailed you
you emailed me back
i'm so grateful for you i told you how
grateful i am for you
even though it's hard because especially
if you're sort of fundamentally in
mathematics just fundamentals like just
basic algebra
and geometry and stuff you can handle
the slow pace you have to sort of
pause the video a lot and uh take notes
and take screenshots but i highly
recommend watching his lectures
on this because uh picking it up to the
next levels
like i have this scenario i've been
telling people now on the program that
it took me it took me five years to
learn what the word recursion meant
because in 2015 uh douglas hofstetter
and
girdle escher bach introduced me to
recursion right but i didn't get it
and i didn't get it in 2016 or 2017 or
2018 2019 maybe a little bit in 2020
i finally realized that i have to
storytell myself to
understand what it means because nobody
ever told me that if you see a seed
like an acorn that becomes an oak tree
that drops more acorns that become more
oak trees
or like humans that birth more humans
which grow up get married and have more
humans
that that's recursive right and nobody
taught me that and so i had to discover
that and storytelling myself and now
there's these like
like two weeks ago we had this uh this
guest that just came over for a little
bit there wasn't an interview with him
his name's shea and what happened was he
he's like 23 years old and he didn't
know what recursion was
and in the span of 30 seconds of telling
him those stories about
about plants and humans right and how
that that's recursive
he's like i give recursion yeah and so
i'm like it's
kind of like revealing it's you already
know it's just it's just it's just
it's like it's remembering it yeah and
it's also storytelling it to make it
more efficient that's right
that's right for me right and so for me
with niles
you eric weinstein all these people that
are trying to
tell me what the hop vibration is what
quaternions are
what an idea of like a geometric unity
could look like
um how to visualize a 4d projection
in 3d space right
it's i've viewed this how many times now
i've seen this i've probably seen this
you know maybe 15 or 20 times in the
last
uh you know three years let's say and
i'm still
uh i feel like the early stages of
recursion
right right right right yeah as it as it
as
as it kind of locks down and gets over
it gets the picture of it i'll
revisit it just like we revisit the
movies or the books or the songs and we
see more of the detail we understand
right yeah right so i'm going to keep
doing this
yeah i mean that's the beauty of it i
mean this is where the uh
the tie back to you know like learn
learning
of an art or or learning music the whole
the whole key is that
where you're really not thinking about
the
the doing of it it's it it becomes
or organic it becomes part of you you
know so there's never any
that's it i have to say personally it's
like it's like it's very difficult for
me to say
any any book that i've been exposed to
that i've dove into i can't say i
completed it totally exactly it's like
i would go back to it i would find
something i've never seen before
yeah yep yeah
that's what it's always funny when you
sort of see
um this uh
phenomena of like when you are at like
an art gallery and there's the speed at
which people move through the art
right and some people go three seconds
move to the next
three seconds some people can spend an
hour looking at one
right and draw more and more out of it
right in this case i would say the same
thing's true with these
abstract maths and physics uh
artificial intelligence theories of
everything philosophy
spirituality all these sciences
in a sense the the the paradox
is that you are already it like rumi
says you are the diamond necklace that
is already
around your neck so stop going around
from room to room
but at the same time realize that we are
that work in progress that is trying to
re-baseline constantly to higher states
of consciousness
closer and closer to god consciousness
christ consciousness buddha
consciousness infinite consciousness
right and that
that's why it takes
patience uh and that love along the
journey to realize that i'm
perfectly fine with coming back to this
over time to keep getting more and more
of it
but i'm not going to give up which i see
so many people
do which is that it's like a
feeling it's this this uh tyranny of the
ego
you know ultimately and that that seems
to be continuing to be the message for
me personally it's like
it's like kill the ego you know yeah
it's like the pain
the pain is the pain has been caused by
that character
yeah yeah it's uh and
as ken wilbur says transcendent include
the ego
transcendent include the the
social consciousness ethnic
consciousness planetary consciousness
transpersonal consciousness and then you
kind of basically live
in some sort of a non-dual symphonic
consciousness where you feel the
symphony
the oneness of all being but you also
express yourself uniquely artistically
as an
artist right which requires a little bit
of some sort of an idea of what it means
to be an individual
i guess yeah yeah yeah it's very uh
i find it both beautiful and confounding
simultaneously yes
yes yes i love this i'm so happy that
we have this actually i think when eric
was on
joe rogan he said that this is the
like most beautiful visualization that
we have available to us on the plan
yeah yeah yeah yeah i agree with the hot
footbridge i totally agree
really yeah you do too yeah yeah that's
as far as as far as
as far as a grand
computer graphics visualizations i
totally agree
yeah yeah so i aspire to go you know
next to that direction yeah i agree and
i think is terence also is
is wanting to go in this direction this
is what you guys are about yeah
so interesting i want to also go in this
direction with our animated series and
all this type of stuff like this
it'd be fun to have one of the modules
in the animated series literally be
about like hot vibrations like one of
the places that chimps go to try and
learn about the nature of reality is
literally to the
scientists the spiritual leaders that
are studying what quaternion arithmetic
is
and what these 4d projections into 3d
space are this type of thing that'd be a
fun little
module and then the kids would play
before the episode and after the episode
with the right
with what like the grant sanderson style
right uh
right mathematically well it it it
invites you to spend a lot instead
instead of feeling oh i have to learn
this for the test or whatever and i was
like
it's like it invites you to spend a lot
of time enjoying it from many different
perspectives because
it they are so intriguing you know it's
like a beautiful flower
it's like what is this and you want to
spend time with us yes
yeah it's awe it's driven by
awe and that that's that's the thing and
it's also very user experience
friendly is the other key thing like
what you're showing us with
with um with the vu lobby and all of the
different um portals
let's let's go let's go um there's there
we are going to have an example right of
of one more uh portal
into another sort of non-cartesian right
is that right
or no i think i think we go
this is the this is the flying flying
through along the unit of the
the solar system here yep and uh uh
but uh uh i think we we end with
schauberger here just linking up with
okay there's here's your your toroidal
consideration
and then the harmonic uh
this was looking at the the one cycle of
saturn
you know which is interesting we're
coming up to this grand conjunction
right now the 21st so that's that's
that's a cross section of what i was
just showing you there
of december well this is the the one at
the bottom there is
that's the the path of the solar system
yeah that's one of the
visualizations of what
uh okay this is from right right and you
start seeing
you start seeing this yes this uh uh
that signal is this some
the sine wave that's on the outside
that's saturn that's saturn
okay cool and then earth is there in the
middle in the middle right the very
the very smallest would be mercury yeah
and and and once again here's your
frequency relationship you know as you
as you scale down
along that radius that one over r your
frequency goes through the roof and this
is
this is the part of the the you know the
spectral analysis of everything
ascension increases yeah yeah
right interesting then into that whole
dirac
you know world yeah of that spike you
know so
that is potentially our metaverse
recursion which well i guess we'll we'll
see if that's the case
in our in our lifetime
so i think that was we i think i brought
in something about
the the trees here oh this is this is
the one over r
right and then then the hyperbolic
analysis is once again
victor schauberger just super uh
inspirational
this book uh living energies that i
highly recommend
and uh just the the what what comes out
of one over r
as a consideration harmonically
and then uh then then this this life
force what the what that
what living energies are and yeah and
how to how to
how to just from uh there's a very
simple
question it's like how do how do trees
defy gravity
you know and uh you know
though one of the the lines that i enjoy
bringing up thinking about newtonian
philosophical materialism is
is why newton didn't figure out why the
how
the apple got up in the tree in the
first place
they gotta find a joke in there
and just yeah it's another way to ask
the question is like
how often do you contemplate your source
yeah
it's just another way to ask the similar
question which is that
the more that we contemplate our source
the more that we contemplate the nature
of our consciousness
awareness existence being reality
and literally dedicate time to it one of
the funny things is that
there seems to be like in modernity
there seems to be this mantra
in modernity which is that
uh i don't need to spend time on
investigating truth
like i don't know why but there seems to
be that mantra like to me
there seems to be there's like this very
big resistance
of consciousness to investigate its own
nature
like so the va it's almost considered
it's considered i mean
it's disparaged right yeah anything
anything in that world and it's like
you know you're you're chasing
uh uh what's the word for it
just uh uh oh man it's gonna it's gonna
elude me for such a status basically
you're chasing stat stat it's it's like
i wanna i wanna signal
how how together and write it right in
the the
just most uh uh
you're the perfect example of of society
you know this is
what politicians had up until recently
been put on pat oh this is the best
example of
of culture and this is my you know and
and then that chasing status all the
time
and and i i think this is why like
the the hermetic tradition and and
you know by by just straight out of the
words it
it demands that difficult
searching of yourself and knowing the
the the
uh commitment to know yourself you know
yes and that's like that's always been
that's the
that's that's the mantra you know that
is difficult yeah
it's like the perfect reality design
where there's only
a very small amount of
people that are actually undergoing the
investigation
of awareness so it's like something like
uh
this is one that i've been um that i've
been playing with that's been pretty fun
is the
the iceberg analogy
so see if i can get it to show up for
you guys
yep all right awesome so
basically that the
the top left corner is the subject
that spends the vast majority of its
time
investigating the object in this case
it's the cell phone right that's the
most
that's the one that's kind of four
billion people have now and spend most
of their time
right doing the object with right and
then
the the second one the one right below
that where you kind of
get to where the surface of the tip of
the ice curve iceberg is meeting the
water which then goes to the bottom of
the iceberg
is kind of like what happened did you by
chance see the documentary the social
dilemma
so the basically what happened was it
was a big
investigation into what's going on as a
planet
around our relationship with the devices
okay
right and with the business plans and
the tech companies and the asymmetry and
data and all this stuff right
but that's why the box is on the arrow
now
because the the subject becomes aware of
their relationship
with the object right right okay so now
we get to
we get a little deeper right okay and
then that sort of
next step is when the subject
investigates another
subject and then there begins to be some
sort of a realization
of the self in the other right so that
hermetic that
know thyself spiritual perennial
tradition
right and then the very sort of last one
is when the subject investigates its own
nature right yeah it gets
that right right beautiful yeah and so
and the reason why it's in the excuse me
the reason why it's in the order that it
is is because
the that sort of surface level
iceberg at the very top although it's
only
10 of the iceberg or so the peak
of the iceberg let's say 90
of civilization apparently spends its
time
in that only surface level looking at an
object relationship whereas the bottom
of the iceberg which is where you get
potentially 90
of the experience of the nature of being
and consciousness and reality
which is when you have a true gnosis of
what know thyself actually means
embodied
right only maybe 10 percent of people
are actually
undergoing or less right the actual true
expression
do we know that though it's an
approximation it's a ballpark
i know what you're saying but it's but
is that part of the illusion too
and is that a reflection of yourself as
far as from a recursion
is that is that a reflection of your own
internals right
yeah yeah um
you know evan bliss one of my close buds
he says that
consciousness in many ways is subjective
storytelling so in this sense yeah i'm
sitting here subjectively storytelling
to people
right this is the nature of life right
right right
you're your own politico religious uh
yeah
uh uh uh forced to be
reckoned with you know but my my but my
by next thank you my next question would
be
would be something like as has that mind
yeah yeah exactly as are you
that's right my next question would be
something like uh
am i wrong that would be my next
question in the sense of
is it better for consciousness it's too
fun to say yes
so yeah exactly yeah yeah i don't know i
don't know because because if
if if this was in a sense wrong
like if people were to say that well
alan it's not that important for
consciousness to investigate its own
nature
you know right then then it would be
like there's no point to go to the
depths of the iceberg whatever you don't
need to be in that submarine
able to investigate the depths of the
iceberg right right which
that part of the analogy is also
important which is that being at the
surface level
the water pressure is easier to deal
with
yeah right so you have to add that part
into the analogy as well yeah
because you could turn it upside down
you know and then it's like then then
you're like well
you know lower on the ground at the at
the top and then
as you transcend you get up to the there
you go
but anyway exactly there's all different
representations
what's the spirit of how does it strike
you yes yes
exactly exactly so this is uh one of the
uh for those that are uh
adamant uh watchers of our of our
program this is one of the
added graphics to the high level
perception project
which uh will be published in the hard
and soft cover versions
and the online version before christmas
so exciting yeah well it's exciting
because
there's a couple bonus like graphics and
bonus content
that i didn't publish in the one that i
released at the end of october early
november
and so it's fun though that yeah exactly
it's fun that i get to
sort of like make a tiny like bonus
edition
which is it's a fun thing to be able to
do that right but
uh one thing that we do have to do is we
have to in a sense
surrender at some point to you know when
you when you do publish
like for example like westworld or
whatever like like you publish season
one
you know it's done like you're not going
back and editing season one again right
and so it's the same thing with your
book or your game
in a sense you can update the game and
update the book and stuff like that
and that's why leonardo da vinci
famously said that
art is never finished only abandoned
right that's pro that's true
that's true yeah that's true but i mean
the the opportunity for
for things to always be to to never
reach a state of completion
and it'd be okay is is better now than
it's ever been you know
so they're always the processes just
like
you know where processes versus objects
you know
yeah exactly stasis yes
dynamic versus study yep yep
i mean that's i mean we we crushed it i
mean we just
yeah cool we crushed it that was so fun
awesome
oh my gosh i would love to um
i'd love to do a bunch of things uh i'd
love to
a i'd love to popularize
on a on a deeper level across the planet
the idea of simulation design
right we got to make that happen because
this whole process of what we've done
this episode
is it's it is
the subject investigating itself this
whole process right yeah
right yeah right so we know i've had to
go through the alchemical process with
it as you might imagine
so it calculate all those
i love it the more you get into
simulation design the more you undergo
the alchemical process
yeah exactly exactly yeah so first of
all that so let's popularize that so if
we
you know what maybe what we can do is we
can uh
like er like early next year maybe in a
month or two we can do like a round two
where we unpack simulation design just
in even more detail
like we were doing today maybe we can
bring terrance on maybe we can bring on
your partner as well yeah like other
people in the space
sure um we can maybe collaborate on
chimps the actual execution the animated
series all these different types of
of things so we have a lot
to look in in into into doing in this
popularization of of the space yeah yeah
yeah
i have a silly question that i like
asking you at the end of the show yeah
okay
dj what is your favorite food
oh man
it's like it goes back to this the thing
that goes into my mind immediately is
is i've only had this like once but it
was like it was a
my dad and i was like fifth or sixth
grade my dad took me to athens
and it was a it was it was a lobster
with like this cheese melted onto it
yeah it's just amazing
every day yeah have you tried remaking
it here or no
no you're just like once once i'm done
no i've never i mean it's it i that's
what came to mind
yeah but you and you've never had it
since then i mean i've had i've tried
but you know no never like never never
that's interesting yeah
yeah yeah it might have been the
atmosphere and just you know
because you were also in athens right oh
that's another thing
too yeah yeah it's like hard to do that
in the kitchen yeah what's yours
uh i don't know yet i've been kind of
yeah i'm trying to figure it out i i
gave a couple
uh one time someone asked me back the
question and i gave some of my
kind of like familial uh home-cooked
food like
borscht and baklava stuff like that okay
right armenian tradition
but also i really like
you know sushi's delicious right but
also one of my friends began answering
the question by literally
taking us to different parts of the
world and telling us what their favorite
food was from all
over the world and i was like that's
another good answer is to literally jump
to the different cultures and begin
saying what's my favorite food
in those cultures right which is another
good one
to sort of to how to answer questions
right lobster's actually come
up on the program quite a bit has it
okay yeah right right
it's it's very rich it's a little
indulgent
especially with cheese sauce it was yeah
no i think you can
yeah right it's heart attack cities
right yes
i love it well
wow thanks for coming on dj
thank you thank you very much for
inviting me yes i appreciate it
so fun and super grateful again andy we
have
so much to still yeah andy create
together yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and
i hope that leslie
see we're you know this is the this is
it this is this
james chris james this is a nodal
cluster
yeah yeah i see
hello take uh take the links in the bio
below
that we have for you to explore the
argos vood argos.vue
also the dot vu check that out as well
also we have dj's linkedin profile we
have becoming borealis.com as well
that kind of acts like his social
posting
place like a blog of awesome high level
things for you to check out they're also
they're all great check those out
comment with what you think in the bio
in the comments below we'd love to hear
your thoughts
on the episode let us know what you
think like the video
share it with other people that you
think would
resonate with learning about simulation
design subscribe if you haven't yet
support the other artists entrepreneurs
spiritual leaders scientists engineers
in your communities around the world
that you believe and support them and
help them grow you can support us
simulation our links are in the bio
below
help us continue executing our goals
here
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
we are undergoing the awakening
given the fact that we are literally
building simulation design technologies
right it's a mechanism for us to awaken
it's so interesting
wow we love you very much thanks for
tuning in we'll see you soon everyone
okay
bye peace